thank you for sharing your point of view
I think that makes courage and it sounds
like this and I think we might be
talking past each other a little bit
because I think you're saying that you
stand for choice and I think a lot of us
are saying that we see a third choice
whether it is you know choice to wear
the hijab or choice not a real job I
think many of us can at least agree on
some of those yeah the issue at point is
choice to do something our choice not to
do something and I'm wondering to talk a
little bit more about you said in the
beginning that there's you have kind of
a difficulty with parts of globalization
that it's in your face all the time
McDonald's and Mecca and I'm wondering
if choice is a central point of that if
then per part of your being a practicing
Muslim would be that you could just not
choose to go into McDonald's or it you
could rally people who believe like you
to get McDonald's to get out of that
particular City you know let me see the
thing is what I'm saying is that this is
what people see as globalization just I
don't mind having Donald net cut
personally I think it's actually a very
cheap way of eating and it provides
choice you can go at the showroom or you
can eat them example I don't have a
problem with that I'm saying this is
what people see it as but it's an
invasion of other just global companies
that are taking over economically
they're not seeing the other parts of it
they're not seeing globalization as
something that could be a two-way street
that involves more than economy so I use
that example just you know because of
the mm but
you know the World Trade Organization
with the trade issues with a little bit
of tweaking here and there I think
that's a very good example of how you
utilize strengths of countries and
fortunately some countries go into
negotiations and a friend of mine works
in the World Trade Organization not
knowing exactly what they should be
doing and therefore getting the wrong
advice and then ruining their own
economies so there are great examples of
globalization I don't think you know
mainstream people outside of maybe
Harvard Yale and you know the Beltway
would understand that so this needs to
be part of their collective
understanding over the globalization is
versus the McDonald's and Mecca it's
just about somebody else coming in and
putting their shop in my place and me
losing economic activity does that
explain okay